So, let me go back to my original question.
What is environmental science?
There are various branches that exist inside and outside of the field.
These can be broadly categorized as atmospheric sciences, ecology,...
...environmental chemistry, geosciences, and environmental assessment.
Atmospheric science studies the phenomena of the Earth's gaseous outer layer...
..with an emphasis on its relationship to other aspects of the biosphere.
Ecology, at its most basic level, analyzes the dynamics of a species in a given area...
...and some aspect of its environment.
Environmental chemistry focuses on chemical alterations in the environment...
...including soil contamination and water pollution.
The next branch is the geosciences.
These include disciplines such as geology, physical geography, and geomorphology.
The last branch is environmental assessment, which is a process of appraisal...
...through which environmental protection and sustainable development are considered.
So, what is the basic approach that differentiates them from the earth sciences...
...and binds them together as environmental science subjects?